welcome to this video playing amateur at
blitz maybe for a change that's not so
bad really I know it has a terribly dull
reputation but it's only because a white
players quite often really don't play it
in a in an interesting fashion you can
play it interestingly like I'm like I'm
trying here grabbing the porn and tried
to keep it that's an interesting way to
play and let's see what happens of
course if you play it with c3 III and
just very passively then it's it's a bit
dull but this year is an interesting
position if he goes b6 I can give the
check I could actually take on be eight
and then give the check this could be
interesting maybe you should go knight
c6 okay something else if I take now I'd
give this check he cannot interpose with
the piece because of c 6 cm and I'm
winning I'm just interesting if I give
the check and he plays Bishop d7 and
then I take on vit can take be fire
that's not that's not good okay let's
say I take and give the check he goes to
yourself now terrible is it when I can
just take me six after that may be
interesting check yeah if he goes
somewhere somewhat to d7 I place is six
and threaten after the piece moves is
seven winning the leg resigns oh that's
early really you can play King e7 I mean
it's it's it looks it looks so stupid
but what
this is what he needs to do now the
computer points out c6 actually I
thought I could take but c6 was probably
even better yeah now this is this is
really great really great for white
let's say he tries to develop I can yeah
I have have an extra pawn on top of all
of that and this configuration with
really paralyzes black yeah this the
London system is it has the reputation
of being a really down mens opening and
okay they are more exciting openings but
still you can't play it in an
interesting fashion this is this is one
example if you go see 5 this is a good
line ready this is some something that
that can be recommended I actually play
it right here because this fields are a
bit more precise to me if this then the
capture is indeed interesting um one
point is that if he gives the check
there's this idea 93 Queen takes an
all-night b5 and here black is forced to
play Knight a6 simply because of this
for Connor c7 and here white it's a bit
more comfortable he has got good
development and the night on a 6 is a
bit misplaced white has good control
over here I've as the night is not on c6
as it should be and this we saw in the
game leads to interesting play I think
he must play 96 I don't know he must
place a bit it's a bit hard maybe but
it's certainly better than b6 this is
more interesting then I need to go we
should be five and I'm keeping an extra
porn here it's not like black it's just
just equal to anything we should be
seven and then you can try to protect
it's I don't know it's unclear so no
it's not a parent how black is going to
get the porn back and it's interesting
simply it's not a dart position um if
you play ambitiously you can some yeah
and inject some life into even very dull
looking openings for example here just
to add a bit more content to this video
if black plays c5 there is this funny
counter gambit efore takes d5 and this
is like an Albin's counter gambit with
Bishop f4 as an extra move which makes
it probably playable the Albans is not
really great maybe since the song eh
maybe a displayable but it's not really
great this is interesting however on my
plate this is black in a tournament game
and I can say that it's not easy to
handle I think black is ok but it's also
an interesting try for white to to stir
up some trouble yeah ok very short game
and still hope you got something out of
it maybe some ideas related to to this
line thanks for watching